manas président de bain le ministre mes
chers collègues m'ont rappelle le
règlement se base sur la sec 36 et 37 de
notre règlement de la ministre ça fait
15 ans que je siège dans cet hémicycle
je n'ai jamais entendu aucun ministre
attaqué aussi violemment en frontal les
sénateurs de façon aussi aussi violente
de façon aussi injuste et de façon aussi
méprisante et je tiens absolument à ce
que votre comporte ce que c'est que ce
rappel au règlement figure à notre
compte rendu parce que je crois qu'on ne
pourra pas laisser votre intervention
sans suite j'espère que le président du
sénat la lira je pense que l'ensemble
des présidents de groupe va va réagir à
votre déclaration jamais je ne suis pas
la seule dans cet hémicycle j'ai été
outré par la façon dont vous vous êtes
exprimés et la façon dont vous méprisez
la haute assemblée
merci chers collègues étaient données de
votre rappel au règlement madame
jacqueline eustache brinio pour rappel
au règlement
aux propos de ma collègue nathalie
goulet d'ailleurs madame la ministre
s'est adressé à moi là m'a agressé
déclariez dans l'hémicycle n'est pas
très bien compris simplement nous avons
droit ici comme ailleurs c'est une
assemblée c'est le parlement d'exprimer
des opinions différentes de celles du
gouvernement et je pense tout comme ma
collègue nathalie goulet c'est tout à
fait scandaleux qu'un ministre
interpelle les parlementaires en les
empêchant pratiquement d'exprimer ce
qu'ils ont à dire et en mettant en cause
leur parole je trouve ça scandaleux donc
moi je veux aussi que ce soit noté un
rappel au gouvernement il remplace
madame la ministre qui a des règles qui
a des lois qui a du respect et que le
conduit bien n'est pas toujours celui
que l'on imagine merci cher collègue ait
est donné de votre appel règlement
madame ferrat un rappel au règlement
également
oui mais de la présidente madame la
ministre quelle fierté a été la nôtre
lorsque vous avez porté les couleurs de
la france au cours de votre carrière
sportive mais quelle déception à vous
entendre aujourd'hui de caldwell de quel
droit proférées vous ces propos
insultants à notre endroit
connaissez vous madame la définition de
la démocratie
vous auriez pu argumenter vous préférez
insulté quel courage michel savin
effectué à l'insa blement est depuis
longtemps moi je suis là depuis vingt
ans j'ai toujours vu michel travailler
inlassablement pour le sport c'est
quasiment cela s'apparente à un
sacerdoce vous brandissez le drapeau de
votre majorité comme une vérité c'est à
voir force est de constater que la
politique dans le sens noble du terme
vous est particulièrement étrangères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]